california democratic governor gavin
newsom has issued pardons
and commuted sentences for 35 current
and former
convicted felons that includes 10
pardons for immigrants facing
deportation
the governor's office says deportation
and permanent family separation
of the formerly convicted immigrants
were unjust collateral consequences
of their previous convictions we're
getting some new information tonight
about what the biden administration
immigration policy might entail
correspondent jeff paul shows us tonight
from los
angeles a change of tone is in the works
at the u.s mexico border
as president-elect joe biden aims to
undo president trump's immigration
platform both in attitude and in policy
there will not be another foot of wall
constructed
in my administration but the roughly 400
miles constructed so far
won't come tumbling down also in store a
renewed focus on daca
the deferred action for childhood
arrivals program
daca protects more than 600 000 people
who were brought to the u.s as
children from deportation for me like
this elections meant everything because
it meant that i'm about to finish my
college
degree and then i can get a job biden is
signaling
he will withdraw a travel ban on people
visiting from 13 countries
several of which are muslim majority in
addition the former vp is focusing on
reuniting hundreds of kids who were
separated from their parents at the
border
during the trump administration they got
separated from their parents
and it makes us a laughing stock and
violates every notion of who we are as a
nation
but some officials along the border have
a warning the system can easily be
overwhelmed
and and when that happens we will revert
back and see another crisis like we saw
in 2014 with unaccompanied alien
children
they say a softened stance could have
huge consequences
if we continue to send a pattern to the
world that all you have to do is get
into the u.s and at some point we will
legalize you there will be no
penalty for that then you can do the
math it would be very problematic
most of the trump immigration policies
the biden administration wants to undo
are somewhat vulnerable that's because
several were done through executive
action
without the approval of congress brett
jeff thank you